[Music]
I first entered foster care at 11 months
I found myself adopted at the age of
nine so I remember walking into the
courtroom and the judge smiling at me
asking me a very important question at
the age of nine and the question was was
did I want to be adopted and I wanted to
say no but I was so afraid of what that
no would mean that I said yes and
unfortunately it was a pretty abusive
adoption I found myself not being able
to participate in kind of the holidays
not being able to be part of that
forever family idea right and so by the
age of 13 I was out surfing quite a bit
until I was able to reenter foster care
and when I reinter foster care the
entire conversation was about how was it
that I was going to survive after foster
care what would happen when I aged out
23,000 young people have a similar story
where they turn eighteen or twenty-one
depending on the state that they're in
and they have to figure out how is it
that they're gonna be completely
self-sufficient I think every day people
make choices about other people's lives
and when it comes down to being a young
person in foster care
before you are 18 every single choice is
being made for you and we see the
results right we see 23,000 young people
aged out of the foster care system who
20% will end up experiencing
homelessness within the first two years
we see 3% being able to get a bachelor's
degree and we see almost 50% of young
people underemployed part of being able
to define their own story being able to
define your own journey is that you
really start to be in power to take the
actions that you feel are appropriate
for your life for me I was fortunate
that when I was 15 I was able to
participate in financial literacy
programs I was fortunate enough to be in
a work to learn program where I got to
have a job
practice what money management looked
like went to asset trainings which were
these once-a-month trainings on how to
buy a car how to lease an apartment and
these things really equip me to be ready
for life after foster care but not every
single young person gets that and that's
why our commitment
action is about supporting young people
with a coaching platform on how is it
that they can get from being in foster
care to life after foster care many
systems around the country have a social
worker leading the case plan leading
what will happen in a young person's
life and we need young people to be
involved in what will happen to them
when we think so much about nonprofits
and what it means to be in service to
the people that we serve too many times
people come to the table thinking about
how is it that they can help but think
of us is not about saying how can we
help it's really looking at the
individual and saying you are a whole
and you're complete and how is it that
the folks around you can support you and
coach you through some of the obstacles
that they may have a little bit of
knowledge on but at the end of the day
the young person at the center is the
only person who has to live with these
decisions for the rest of their life
think of us as an online platform that
allows young people to create a
transition plan where they are thinking
about what is it that they want to
accomplish whether that's a two-year
college whether it's four-year what type
of job car etc and empowers young people
to build their own personal advisory
board of already trusted adults in their
lives and people who are working within
the foster care system together they all
work to create a transition plan where a
young person identifies what is it that
they want after high school what is it
that they want after foster care they
get to set goals action steps be able to
access resources on the platform and be
able to watch content that helps them
think through what my life looked like
after foster care at the end of the day
all the research and everything that we
know to be true about humanity is that
the connection between humans is what
really supports folks in their healing
what really positions folks who develop
new abilities to position them to thrive
and so when I think about mentorship I
think about how might we continue to
make sure that young people are
connected with those adults who can see
their needs can see how they can get
involved and be there for them
you